hier kommt alex
er nimmt uns mit auf seine finca im
südosten von mallorca ein hotel auf der
insel sein lebenstraum genau der ist von
der pandemie bedroht
kein gast neben alex zeigt uns was das
für ihn bedeutet
eigentlich möchte ich euch das hier
alles gar nicht zeigen dann sieht schon
sehr trostlos aus also wenn man es
zumindest anders kennt gähnende leere am
pool vier jahre lief das geschäft so gut
jetzt hat alex alle sechs mitarbeiter in
kurzarbeit geschickt
es soll hilfe geben 700 euro
das ist zwar ein tropfen auf dem heißen
stein aber besser als nichts aber
trotzdem muss von diesen geldern noch
nichts geflossen die mitarbeiter habe
auch noch keinen cent gesehen jetzt seit
fünf wochen
der lock down überraschte alex und seine
freundin will quasi über nacht nur drei
tage hatte das paar die finger geöffnet
als ende märz in spanien der
ausnahmezustand ausgerufen wurde
niemand weiß wann wieder gäste auf die
insel kommen eine katastrophe für die
balearen der tourismus macht dort 45
prozent der wirtschaftsleistung aus und
eine katastrophe für die beiden ihre
existenz ist bedroht
er hat einfach so eine harte gefühls
kurve erlebt man unglücklich lehre
enttäuschung hoffnung und jetzt mal wenn
man hier hin fährt wieder
also ich glaube jetzt mit euch einfach
mal durch ist das so man hat alter
schwede was passiert hier gerade und
dann bedanken wieder einfach bewusst wie
schnell das alles aus den angeln heben
kann
[Musik]
wir tauchen ab im roten meer
die deutschen kommen gerne nach dahab
ägypten ingrid l kabbani hat hier seit
32 jahren ein hotel terrorismus kriege
wirtschaftskrise nichts konnte ihrem
projekt etwas anhaben
aber diesmal lief in dieser virus der
schaft ganz ägypten liegt den ganzen
tourismusland in dahab gibt es nur
strand und meer
sonst nichts für urlauber ein traum ohne
urlauber ein albtraum für die einwohner
das ist mein wetter ihnen freund sommer
sommer betreibt einen kleinen fahrenden
supermarkt die meisten menschen hier
leben vom tourismus sie hatten bisher
eine menge arbeit aber jetzt kommt
keiner mehr da ab ist leer
umgerechnet 29 euro corona hilfe zeit
die ägyptische regierung an nun
arbeitslos gewordene bürger der
tourismus in ägypten hatte sich gerade
erholt da hab galt nach jahren wieder
als sicheres reiseziel
[Musik]
calimera von der wunderschönen insel
zakynthos und der familie der ianos ich
bin dimitris koreaners ich freue mich
sehr dass wir wenigstens über dieses
video kommunizieren dürfen
anders geht das im moment auch nicht
denn gäste kann die metris gerade nicht
willkommen heißen
demetrius tochter kind geboren und
aufgewachsen in seinem heimatort hat er
sich ein kleines ferienparadies
aufgebaut
[Musik]
es ist nicht einfach für uns alle
man braucht viel geduld wir müssen stark
sein das ist eine herausforderung für
uns alle
unser ziel ist es uns und alle anderen
zu schützen und hyde ist das höchste gut
dimitris fährt mit uns über die insel
und zeigt uns ein zakynthos im
dämmerschlaf
dabei war griechenland nach zehn jahren
wirtschaftskrise gerade wieder am
erwachen das corona virus beendet die
hoffnung auf aufschwung
griechenland könnte es in der eurozone
am härtesten treffen sollten die strände
noch lange so leer bleiben
[Musik]
die stadt ist komplett still
niemand ist da wie eine postkarte oder
eine postkarte
venedig ein menschenleerer markusplatz
es sind ganz besondere aufnahmen die uns
nicola kato losschickt ein echter
venezianer hier geboren und aufgewachsen
ich arbeite für die agentur fehler
sie gehört der stadt venedig und ist
zuständig für die organisation von
veranstaltungen wie zum beispiel den
karneval
der wurde wegen corona abgebrochen
seit dem 14 märz herrscht in venedig
totale ausgangssperren in den
sommermonaten sind hier bis zu 120.000
touristen am tag
[Musik]
ich gehe hier nur mit zwei tauben das
sind die einzigen die hier gerade sind
sonst ist es hier sehr voll
venedig gehört wieder ganz den
venezianern doch selbst die müssen jeden
spaziergang begründen denn die polizei
patroulliert auf straßen und kanälen die
polizei konnte sie fragen diese frau
warum sie draußen ist nicola darf raus
er hat eine sondergenehmigung der stadt
lange hat venedig über zu viele
touristen geklagt jetzt plötzlich ist
zeit nachzudenken
wir waren sehr genervt von den touristen
die in die stadt eingefallen sind
aber jetzt wo sie wechselt realisieren
wir dass wir nicht mehr richtig leben
die ganze wirtschaft des staates zum
erliegen gekommen
venedig braucht die touristen alles ist
darauf ausgerichtet und so schön die
menschenleere stadt gerade ist lange
geht das so nicht gut das weiß hier
jeder
währenddessen am fuße der pyrenäen hier
im campingbus arbeitet an einem plan b
mein name ist dieter braun und ich bin
in barcelona einen selbst elegischen
kohl affäre kurz vor dem lock down ist
sie zu ihrem deutschen vater gefahren
und sitzt seitdem hier fest wir haben
hier eine kleine küche improvisiert und
hier schlafen mir macht man die matratze
frau und mann kann da schlafen und dass
dich das bild der tiefs dann kannst du
hochklappen und das wird so unsere home
office dieses video hat sie bei uns
geschickt da war noch alles normal auf
dem gaudi food market unter dem toto
bälle school in barcelona ein
touristenmagnet
dort verkauft sie eigentlich ihre selbst
gemachten pralinen jetzt geht sie ihrer
großen leidenschaft im campingbus nach
will die feier zeit sinnvoll nutzen ihr
plan social media in diesem onlinekurs
für chocolatiers wird ihr erklärt wie
sie ihren online auftritt verbessern
kann
denn für sie steht fest ihren stand wird
sie so schnell nicht wieder aufbauen
können mann vorstellen die zukunft und
vor allem die die zukunft von von
finanziell wirklich sehr sehr schwierig
aber man braucht ja geduld und man muss
das leben muss weitergehen
[Musik]
dort wo sie dann normalerweise lebt und
arbeitet hat ein spitzenkoch eine
außergewöhnliche initiative gestartet
hallo ich bin fit ich bin der
verantwortliche koch der vereinigung
food for good zur armenspeisung in
barcelona die ich mit verschiedenen
anderen kirchen gegründet haben weil die
restaurants im ganzen land geschlossen
haben sind viele köche gerade arbeitslos
freiwillig bereiten sie unter coaches
anleitung essen für bedürftige zu gäste
gibt es keine aber genug menschen die
hunger haben die werden jeden tag mehr
wie hier in barcelona vor diesem hotel
die handyaufnahmen coaches zeigen all
die menschen die wieder für kostenloses
essen anstehen wir sind wirklich sehr
besorgt wir wissen einfach nicht wie es
weitergeht
unsere regierung kommuniziert überhaupt
nicht eindeutig wir wissen nicht was mit
den restaurants passieren wird mit den
bars spanien ist einer der wichtigsten
touristen ziele der welt und ohne dass
hotels und restaurants und strände
wieder aufmachen bleibt die situation
hier in barcelona erstmal sehr schwierig
und so bereiten kutsche und sein team
auch heute wieder knapp 1000 mahlzeiten
vor
so wie jeden tag solange die krise eben
dauert
[Musik]
im gegensatz zu spanien hat das virus
das nachbarland portugal nicht so schwer
getroffen
die regierung hat schnell reagiert gut
für die gesundheit schlecht fürs
geschäft
hallo aus portugal ich bin eva ich lebe
seit sieben jahren in lissabon und
arbeitet hier als korrespondentin eva
nimmt uns mit in die alfama lissabon
beliebtestes viertel
normalerweise kommen bis zu sechs
millionen touristen jährlich hierher und
genießen die atmosphäre in den engen
gässchen bei foto und einem glas wein
seit ungefähr fünf jahren erlebt
portugal einen regelrechten
tourismusboom alles war auf den
tourismus ausgelegt und das hat
natürlich wirtschaftliche vorteile mit
sich gebracht aber auch einige
schwierigkeiten für die bewohner
stichwort mietpreise die steigenden
lissabon seit jahren denn fast jede
zweite wohnung in der alfama wird an
urlauber vermietet eva trifft ihre
freundin christina die mit ihrem
portugiesischen mann carlos hier lebt
und eine kleine ferienwohnung hat
carlos arbeitet als it-spezialist die
beiden sind also liegen ausbleiben der
touristen noch entspannt und hält jetzt
für ein paar monate ein standbein weg
ist natürlich sehr bedauerlich bringt
aber die familie nicht zum schutz bei
anderen wird es sicherlich lage anders
ausgehen
gallus und christina erkennen die
vorteile aber auch die schattenseiten
des tourismus sie hoffen dass die krise
der stadt lissabon auch etwas gutes
bringt unheimlich voll voller menschen
viel zu viele menschen und klar dass man
jetzt das gefühl die stadt kann wieder
ein bisschen atmen und das wäre
natürlich schön wenn man durch diesen
frischen atem
ja irgendwie das ein bisschen wieder
sortiert am zweiten mai ist der
ausnahmezustand in portugal gelockert
worden
wann wieder touristen kommen weiß
niemand doch die bewohner machen sich
jetzt schon gedanken wie sie dann mit
dem tourismus umgehen wollen
ich bin willi steindl und ich lebe im
wunderschönen kirchberg in tirol
ein vier sterne hotel in zweiter
generation
willi steindl will sich das von einem
virus nicht kaputt machen lassen
er ist dabei die hygieneregeln der
österreichischen regierung umzusetzen
es wird natürlich herausforderungen für
uns das alles unter einen hut zu bringen
doch ich bin optimistisch und positiv
dass man diese natürlich auch schaffen
damit unsere gäste einen sicherung
schönen aufenthalt bei uns auch in
kronach zeiten haben können
willi steindl will bereit sein wenn die
gäste wiederkommen und vertröstet sie am
telefon
geplant ist am 10 juni aber gewiss
leider nicht wie das jetzt mit den
grenzen ausschaut wenn die grenzen nicht
aufgehen und vor allem auch der deutsche
gast zu uns kommt dann können wir die
betriebe nicht aufspielen weil es
einfach konsum macht und wirtschaftlich
nicht vertretbar ist
von kirchberg bis venedig alle hoffen
auf den sommer und eine welt die sich
wieder eröffnet